hey it's your buddy Zach and it's your
boy Sam we're here at the Teen Choice
Awards blue carpet Busby's end us to
make a video but we don't care about
that we're just gonna try to get as many
selfies with celebrities as possible
all of them holiday do you take selfies
yeah man take a lot of selfies too many
it takes like I took a thousand selfies
good costing we're trying to figure out
how to take amazing selfies on the blue
carpet right now you know what you got
to figure this out together cuz I have a
problem too so for me you have to get
them okay great
done easy I'm just gonna sneak right in
here yeah it's all about the face
obviously go straight on you have to
think like a guy but you channel a
little bit Victoria what's our face
we're gonna like cute a heart
uh excuse me credit like uh what's wrong
well we need to kind of face the Sun a
little bit oh he's turning around he's
figuring this out and then you want to
just like find your light like your
inner light or like the actual oh great
how do you lookin to the Sun do you want
to close your eyes knocking yeah ready
open them on three one two three ha ha
ha ha smile like you're dead inside
having a good time
oh you're gonna kissy face oh yeah okay
so hey roomie so I can take a selfie
with us Snoopy no you're the center of
attention
I had loved it loved it and what you
were like like cuter top yeah you got to
look tough right I never smile smile
yeah smiling is for happy people just
confuse like what yeah pensive well I
can eat for dinner huh did my mom pack
my lunch today
I hope so do your cheekbones bite your
jaw maybe like a happy like what do you
mean you're fighting your chest like
huge clench your jaw and it like makes
your cheekbones that is a pro tip yeah
gotta like turn your head a little bit
like the key is to see when you smell
some people awkward another smelly okay
like you make a weird face nailed it
nails I would double tap and I usually
always take four options love it love it
love it love it I love you too look
relax
look at that amazing let's do cute one
just for fun just for kids boys for the
kids right whenever I take a picture
literally my phone is like 50 of the
same picture of like slightly different
pose who did you take a lot of selfies
no I really don't know selfies I'm not a
selfie type of guy